hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to off a brand new let's
play that you guys have apparently been
dying for there's already been fan art
made of me playing the game and I don't
know a damn thing about it all I know is
that it's very weird very interesting
and should throw me for a loop quite a
few times so I hope you guys enjoy this
if this text is hard to read please
enter the hour I did that I'm good
caution it is possible that certain
scenes in this game are shocking to an
unborn public or maybe not well one of
the other the musical pieces and sound
effects of off created by Elias Conrad
cold wood are an important part of the
game it would be ashamed to play without
them okay unproductive fun time this
game was originally made in French I
believe my name is Mark
[Applause]
okay mark blue the name dub to me but
beer beer your name is markiplier yes
that is correct
I'm a boy last time I checked anyway yep
boy alright welcome mark alright you've
been assigned being called the batter
the batter's has an important mission be
sure that it's accomplished batter look
kind of creepy we let you out in stone
zero good luck
for more information find the one called
the judge Oh
now another thing about this game this
really cool is that it is great
soundtrack and that was what I read but
I also can tell because of the intro
music that I heard that you guys heard
to to move my body use the arrow keys on
the keyboard to interact with the
environment use the spacebar and a key
okey dokey are those buttons over there
can i press him with my dingle-dangle
about my bat cuz i am the batter zone
zero some people said that this game was
inspired by earthbound and earthbound is
one of my favourite games of all time
cannot be any other living beings in
zone zero so I must assume that you are
only a mere figment of my imagination
nevertheless I will introduce myself I'm
the judge and I am aching to know your
name dear illusory interlocutor Ivan the
batter I've been assigned to a sacred
mission it is a pleasure that purring is
weird however is not the puppet I was
addressing but the puppeteer controlling
it what is your name dear puppeteer his
name is markiplier he can't talk to us I
sure as [ __ ] can however he can see R
and CN everything okay even though you
are to our but an inexistent operation
in my eyes let it be said that I am
delighted to meet you as well dear maka
blue I believe we're in need of your
services many people are in need of my
services you know everybody loves cats
especially the internet we rub ourselves
against their legs and Pan the most
existent manner
they adore
that I'm not talking about that kind of
help I see what sort of service could I
offer to an ectoplasmic entity I have a
sacred mission to fulfill
I must purify the world there is no
objective more laudable than yours I
accept to serve you as a guide through
this area if it is of any help to you
thanks ok that was much more agreeable
than where did you go
you're just zippity-doo-dah down out of
here did you jump up
do I need to jump up a lock ticket has
been found God this does remind me a lot
about it's impossible to get around this
obstacle oh yes Insur possible in every
way Oh
4:4 e hos that a B I'm gonna assume that
I need to start writing stuff down ok
fine
4 4 B 2 B 7 C 4 4 B 2 B 7 C now I don't
know how I don't know how well then I'm
gonna be able to get through this game
but I'm gonna do my best not to screw it
up at the time allow me to confess that
I find you quite tangible for a
fantastic Oriole being might you in fact
be a creature of flesh and blood I think
so yes so I've been mistaken from the
beginning you did not have even
interrupt me in my deluded phantasms
this is relatively bizarre I must say
for you're the first living being I was
given a chance to encounter in this lair
I had in fact concluded that zone 0 was
an empty land obviously I was misled
however there are exist there exist
other zones and in those territories of
risk of hostile individuals attacking
you in the most violent manner is quite
high your sacred mission will likely
lead you into these lands would you like
me to teach you the art of violent
confrontation no I think I'm good no
tutorial are you certain yes pretty
senton so are you pretending to be able
to handle that bad with virtuosity
without even eating my wife's business
of advice I offer you that you stay well
more than hot air mentor
impress me because that would be taking
a high risk but I will assume that this
is not the case and that you are
fighters the value we come to be I
certainly am be it as it may your
training has not reached its end yet let
me ask you to follow me if you still
want me to ask your guide why don't you
go
just stop zippen off to nowhere land
hello kitty cat teach me oh yes
pass through here you need to use your
cerebral organ you know the one bathing
flabbily in your tired grain iam I
believe those floating blocks correspond
with the symbols you can see on the wall
in some of the way really ah so these
are floating blocks
well then I suppose I need to press them
in a certain order about oh I am ten
times a genius I thought I was oh wait a
minute what the hell
ahh 100 creep 6 [ __ ] yep nope okay that
so that was right 6 and B is another
word for to be Oh a that is innate ok I
was wrong
8 tall tree oh there we go this ain't so
hard what do you got for me now
Oh finally after all that exertion the
eagerly awaited recompense makes its
entrance to the scene ah
kitty likes his milk all food okay you
uh you have a good time now I have this
other code that I put up on the wall
before from the beginning area 4 4 8 hmm
eight 7c
oh come on that had to be right Oh see
maybe see something different uh four
four eight eat to eat c7c no that ain't
right either but it sure did it good I'm
the best oh that goes there so I could
go back and easily check but I was too
smart a piece of silver flesh has been
found so why did I pick it up
Wow that'd have been important to me all
right whatever I'll carry on that way
here is an accessory that is going to be
especially helpful on your purifying
quest dear enlightened student and
sportive friend it is a cube hovering in
midair as you will have likely noticed
nevertheless you will be able to
differentiate it from similar ones by
the contrast of bad taste it imposes on
your view of its clashing color defying
any sensible course of plastic arts
however do not be judged it too quickly
because despite its criticized Abella
pearance this red cube is of undeniable
use aside from rendering you the
entirety of your health and competence
points it is capable of saving your
progress and sending you to the
nothingness the nothingness is a lieu of
transition outside of space itself where
you can travel from one point to another
at the speed of light I now invite you
to try it out in order to discover
locations more populous than this
deserted land open your wings my dear
companion and hurry away towards the
following zones without hesitation your
only enemy is a fear that will grab you
okay do not worry I to travel a lot
through the different zones of the world
we will newly meet one another
eventually without a doubt oh and by the
by take this this object of a curious
name will be the key that permits you to
enter and Zone one have I clarified that
you can at any time consult you in the
door bye
and characteristics by pressing the
Escape key the leo card has been found
we'll then health point of view save the
game yay let's do this let's return to
the nothingness
whoa well that was quick okay well
that's the new and interesting
interesting sensation how do I get to
the world map what is that over the
whole zone one it is impossible to enter
you need the act act adequate zodiac
card nothing this is a fun place oh yeah
it's very good I'm just gonna go on my
way now that was the same point hello
friend train number one is really useful
means of transport to get about zone 1
okay
Dameon as good as any that I know over
okay I think we're starting to get into
the weird part of this game reminds me
of it did anybody watch me play slender
morass or whatever it was called it was
exceptionally weird game train number 2
hasn't been active for a long time okay
can you stop breathing heavily whenever
I try to talk to people they'll do I
know who you are are you an expected no
I'm the batter
I've come to exterminate the impure
spirits batter the the MBS berries I use
some sort of profit or perhaps a man of
belief yeah something like that
who said you know buddy I'm being led by
market player I don't know him he must
be a member of the superior personnel in
any case that's good it means I
requested been acknowledged here I'm
gonna explain you your tasks what whoa
howie here at the smoke mines of damien
the southern part of zone one here we
send workers into deep tunnels Donner's
metal from the ground for freeing
embedded smoke that was trapped in the
depths yeah I don't know if I made the
right choice giving this guy this wimpy
voice thanks to a variety of tools we
are able to put some of it into bottles
which the Queen sends to the other zones
I guess it's not any weirder than any
other but this game could be the rest of
it flows free forming the air that our
lungs inhale and exhale huh
yeah so we can live mmm smoke yes
breathing it smoke it's good for
everyone
fun for the whole family especially the
kids as the first four elements heads an
important element
smoke smoke is an important element who
cave in because without smoke people
would have nothing to breathe there we
are and so finally how do I put this
where are the impure God I'm the
Inquisition here oh yes there we go
there are many spectres in the mind
they're becoming more and more
aggressive but in fact it would be
better if you didn't enter the minds
because visitors access them so here's
what we're gonna do there's an annex
tunnel that nobody ever goes to but a
miner went in there some time ago and he
saw something strange II said nothing
like the usual so I thought maybe it's
the cheapest Victor's so here's your
task if you accept you'll go into the
annex and kill the chief inspectors then
the spectators will disappear and we can
work properly again there we go there we
you have any questions no pickable the
tunnel is right down there oh that I
just trusted our whole operation do okay
so enough of that one
so you don't be promoted I'll be a
supervisory Noma I'm anxious for that
day to arrive okay thank you
I'll miss steal your stuff I found
another luck ticket you don't need this
to you my bat says you definitely don't
so get out of here
Oh is your home okay don't get out here
um okay so I guess it's about time for
me to face off of this boss ghastly you
what the hello what are you doing down
here what do we have here is that not
markiplier and his picture as jumpin
Jack the batter
are you the spectres leader oh I'm only
passing through not unlike the smoke
which is being extracted from this pale
and metallic blaze
however I believe I know the where the
one you are taking for an ectoplasmic
can be found oh hello to tell the truth
I am perplexed I think it is one of
those peculiar tall objects called a
spherical add-on I have very well tried
to approach it a crow chip but the
operation has failed systematically so
far but I am thinking maybe you one who
does not have a physical order will
succeed in affiliating the spiritual
entity to yours okay fine whoa what an
exceptionally intriguing phenomenon I
must admit that I remained that last by
this unexpected metaphysical reaction
fair enough since it has decided to
accompany you I know only to advise you
to make the best possible usage of it
got it the chief of the spectres isn't
here sorry but I fear I have to respond
in the negative
apart from this add-on I have not
crossed all the way of a single soul in
this loo so don't know how to pronounce
that well thanks for nothing yeah well
I'm out of here I'm gonna strut my stuff
on the way out of here I love that walks
out by the way Hey okay I did it
you killed the chief inspectors no he
wasn't there oh oh really
oh bugger crap I well then uh I believe
it I'll have to let you enter into the
main gorgeous tan yeah
laughter but the regulations oppose it
all right suppose is a very specific
okay so stated in paragraph five so uh
good
the main mind zero on the right fair
okay all right thanks buddy
just let it any stranger with a bat on
the way through there are phantoms down
there they keep us working properly Oh
dad's back time for me anyway who cares
if they're killing everybody in droves
what are you doing here you the mind
inspector yes I am don't I look official
to you fine I guess it's guiding me to
my destination
you've come to eliminate the spectres
that's good news that was this who's
there the lamps don't always work in the
odd most corridors and since everything
looks the same around here it's easy to
get lost
good know there are phantoms in every
corridor be careful mister and besides
it was let you enter that normally the
regulations probably the external
visitors okay I'm just gonna charge on
in all bold like excuse me
show yourself corrupting children
alright boys are forgiveness that
eliminate your calamitous forms mistake
here prepare yourself to suffer my
judgment what am i Batman oh I am the
batter verification in progress Otto
someone said that Otto's actually pretty
good if I didn't want to know how to
play but I might try to i'ma try to do
this okay so I get it's like a
turn-based thing I gotta wait for my
bing-bong bing-bong suck it
yeah oh she's so my god
what the hell just happened I wasn't
that music sorry talk about bad
get a TI brained you you're gonna use
I'm gonna try we'll see what competence
is pretty sure okay there's there's no
confidence attack
well you speared him Oh
oh my goodness thank you for that suck
on that
oh I didn't kill you why didn't they
kill you
maybe the batter has some Commodus
points or Commodus stuff that I can use
[ __ ] okay
wide angle there we go boom oh come on
that doesn't lb at all allow is a big
waste of time I don't need to know about
them I'm the batter I'm just gonna care
if their brains in not care cave smash
the brains in that's all I need to know
- music that's like a weird mixture of a
bunch of different types messing with my
brain
get used to this because apparently
there's a lot of this in the game there
you go you phantasm adversaries purified
400 experience 80 credits not to you
look ticket ticket not ticket what a
lack tickets do doctor time this add-on
is fighting by my side that's practical
let's purify the other galleries I love
album like I seriously am an inquisition
wait a minute oh the yellow box yarn the
same I see get out of my way to the
deeper bowels well hell the deeper
bowels of the smoke mines yeah so a
joker has been found good thing
oh hello oh well the hell you might try
the auto see what happens all the auto
does is just make it a little easier on
me finger my circle why the hell did you
do that okay this seems to be going well
okay so Otto is this if I'm running
through an area and I don't want to have
to deal with it myself like if I ever
want to skip ahead I'm trying to get
from point A to point B in this let's
play I'm gonna do that just to get
through it all right so there's
apparently a lot of these guys I'm
working on being productive no you're
not you're hiding away from the ghosty
goos do you want me to purify use world
your are some weird ass weirdos okay a
purified m240 Locke ticket what are the
log tickets do maybe the luck tickets
will make me critical strike a lot on
there's a door but it seems to be locked
from the inside
wait a minute what's that light out okay
who's too smart for you ah when you run
out of meat what exact meat are you
eating here why'd you open the door
inspectors good attackers go quickly
three pieces of Lyles mean oh why do I
want Lyle's meat but I certainly don't
want it in my mouth
top what are you all doing here you
cowards get up there and fight use your
back to purified in the infidels I feel
like I'm from Warhammer 40k does anybody
else I'm very intrigued by the Warhammer
like all the Warhammer stuff but I've
never actually bothered to read up on
much of the lore besides this what's
available on the wikis but I want to
read the books like the Horus heresy
books at least God that is such an
in-depth thing there's so much to
Warhammer oh no oh no alphas dead he's
dead when did he dead I thought he was
healed by the goobie gavest once he's
taking some damage for me some Chronicle
migraine me get out of here
okay there we go ads for series purified
I got a bunch of luck tickets because
apparently luck tickets I've read up
they give you health back so where's
that damn yellow box I need to recover
my where it's the damn yellow box
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna run into another one
before who I hate I hate random
encounters but it's something that's
just a huge part of this type of game
okay it's my guy yeah he's good he's
good my guys all better now so I need to
find something in this place
a I believe I don't even understand
anything that's going on here but in a
way I kind of oddly oh you dig back
and there we go battle over ooh my awful
leveled up what a goody good gumdrop
to pieces of Peleus meat so am I gonna
combine these piece oh come on
so anyway am I gonna combine these
pieces of meat to make a giant I don't
know what I did but it killed him dead
dah bout a little anyway I'm gonna
combine these pieces of meat to make a
big old piece of super meat that I need
to use give me that give me that okay
all healed up all better now
Balbina yes but there are loads of
specters down there yes hi you inspector
No then who are you have you been sent
by the queen of bite a Don no but you
still know how to fight this practice
yeah you had destroyed them
yes oh that would be great we have
spectres in our big barns bond yes I
like out I like us to sing time Oh more
history lessons I like yeah you're at
the metal farm stead of a pen tell the
eastern part of Zone one this game this
is gonna get complicated I looked it up
this game takes about five and a half
hours to be ours work consists of
cutting lifestyle could do it
ah but extracting the Botanic boulders
that were contained in the cadavers
watch what why doesn't sound seem right
huh all the poor quality medalists
discarded foreman ground we walk on what
the rest gets purified to make tools and
the other object with huh we'll run that
by me again we're walking on cow rocks
dead cow rocks some of it also it put
into crates and sent out their zones so
they have tools and soil as well as bows
as the first of four elements it's an
important element No
Moke is the first of four elements I
think didn't they say that because
without metal people would have nothing
to walk on they would sink and drown
there and those we have spectres in the
large barns
I must purify the mines first yes but
the parts are that big and who Dean I
see you to take care of them fast
because the Queen's inspectors gonna
arrive at any moment so could you take
care of those barns all right it's not
like my progress was impeded anyway now
do big I'll be done quickly yeah so you
say what can I say where's a savvy
pointy do give me a say be do where's
the savvy doodad huh find whatever I'll
do without a save come on bring it on
I'm gonna cure purify yeah Garda purify
you shouldn't get attached the animals
once you are in oh it's difficult to put
your hands inside
no thank you
oh this games gonna get weird isn't it
this games already getting weird but I
have a feeling it's gonna get weirder
does that why people like it so much
because so disturbingly strange these
balls are clusters of work Medal which
are going to be sent to other zones it's
a metallic thanks for your expertise sir
alright whatever let's do this God
destroy the specter oh here I go look
there are five spaces left in this bond
come on you those how about uh Claudia
how about a smack your Oh your new
battle man I'm still gonna clobber you
yeah you can scream all you all know
finger my circle man oh that's right get
out of here
Oh what wait what happened oh my god you
spawned us what it how did he spawn ass
what was really sets I need to figure
out what that was going on before I lose
my mind even further all right they're
here okay yay silver flesh all right
come here you douche yes right here Oy
I'm gonna cry yeah I mean look at my
cabinet door this fingering me maybe
yeah baby boom oh come on I'm so blind
boom
purified 180 experience silver flesh
received yeah yeah you want to stay away
from our cows buddy you can order them
don't touch my cows are you freaking out
ah the Otto's a better father than I am
apparently good cows you're welcome I
can't save you and you don't need to
thank me none
you are beautiful creatures new don't
move me so weirdly okay I'm just gonna
carry on I'm gonna I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go away career officer is purified
uh the batter aw crap I done goofed
already didn't I frig of Rass down here
I'm coming to get ya Tavia teleport back
to the barns entrance well that's all oh
thank you that was awfully convenient
you saved me some time oh hello
inspector aren't you Tandy
before [ __ ] you are freaky is Frick
frack long no no of course nothing I
could've guessed and why does he think
he's capable of destroying those stupid
randoms he thinks he's better than you
[Music]
[Applause]
you think you're smarter than everyone
else but you were all the same
that's hardly important let's go slow
erase that three yeah you see he won't
succeed
Goo's knows nobody is capable of finding
the Phantom's other than the Queen's
offices listen you wouldn't be in so
much [ __ ] I could have done it but you
deserve light
they ain't constantly telling your
teacher off no I command you get the
[ __ ] out of my where is this and if you
ought to keep your job oh now the batter
shows up perfect timing I just save I'm
on our way
thanks for nothing moon who was that
person oh yeah Joe life yes and the
spectres dead eradicated the barn is
pure now that you here must be very
lucky
I have many love tickets who was that
person that was Thursday Don she was the
queen supervisor you me inspector
no the Queen doesn't employ specters a
happy one but he's hostile I must
destroy him I like this guy I like him a
lot straight to the point with the
batter he's an envoy of the Queen you'd
better go complete your work and the
smoke mines please hmm besides he said
he's another but no one could go there
without proper authorization so please
return to the smoke mines all right well
that's it then I love this guy so much
okay so either way this has been off or
at least the beginning of it I'm going
to be doing a full playthrough of it I'm
gonna try to make it as interesting as
possible I know there's a little be a
lot of combat in there I'm going to try
to hurry through that so you guys don't
have to sit through all of the fights
and you guys can progress through the
story just fine you welcome everybody so
if you're enjoying this series please
let me know in the comments below leave
a like if you are and thank you all so
much for watching prepare for more off
and thank you everybody who pushed me to
play this game thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]